So today we're going to talk about how
to burn your belly fat extremely fast
this is an extension of a previous video
I did on five important tips So today
we're going to cover the sixth through
the tenth tip but let me just do a quick
recap for those of you that have not
seen the first video and I will put a
link down below because that's a really
important video that you get as a
foundation okay all right tip number one
if our goal is to burn the most fat we
want to get the body into a state of
ketosis and ketosis is keeping your
carbs very very low okay and I'm talking
about your net carbs net carbs are the
total carbs minus the fiber carbs and
there are certain carbs that you don't
count as the part of a ketogenic plant
and those are the Leaky green salads but
we don't count those carbs because we
want to include those carbs because of
the amount of potassium magnesium
vitamin C and a lot more nutrients
including the final nutrients so salads
even though they're mostly carbohydrate
they're the type of carbohydrates that
are not going to be a problem they're
not going to raise insulin so if you
have a large salad you're eating a lot
of fiber that even though it's a
carbohydrate it won't trigger insulin so
fiber and fat are the two things that
won't trigger insulin and this is why
you want to put olive oil on the salad
as a pure fat so that way we don't
trigger insulin as well and then on top
of that we want to put vinegar you can
do balsamic or apple cider vinegar
because vinegar is another thing that is
really good to help regulate your blood
sugars as well as lower insulin despite
you even eating some carbs so that
vinegar is going to be very very
important and the other tip I'm going to
recommend is eat your salad first then
the protein and fat because if you do it
the other way around eating your protein
or fat first you may not be hungry
enough to finish the salad and of course
I do recommend seven to ten cups of
salad per day it might seem like a lot
but when I talk about about seven or ten
cups I'm talking about small handfuls
okay so it's not that much next thing is
protein the size of protein you need is
between three and a half ounces to six
ounces maybe seven or eight depending on
your size so if you're a male you need
the protein the size of the palm of your
hand times two if you're a female just
have one serving of protein the size of
the palm of your hand just to keep it
really really simple
of course this is going to vary
depending on your age your metabolism
your activity level if you work out Etc
it's also going to vary if you're going
to do two meals a day or one meal a day
the less meals that you have per day of
course you're not going to have the same
amount is if you were to have two meals
because that's just a tremendous amount
of protein so when you start doing
things like Omak or meal a day your
requirements for these nutrients even
amino acids go down because the body
starts to adapt the other important
point about protein is to make sure that
you don't do the lean protein okay you
want the fattiest protein you can find
because there's something called the
insulin index and that is the index that
relates to Foods increasing insulin if
you were to do no fat protein like whey
protein powder you would trigger insulin
a lot more than if you had some other
fatty meat or fattier protein so make
sure that if you're eating chicken you
have the skin on it make sure you have
fish have the skin on it and consume the
fattiest fish that you can find like
sardines are really good in their own
oil versus just in water and either eat
a Patty steak or maybe hamburger with
paramounts of fat this is just going to
keep your insulin levels the lowest
possible all right number three is
dietary fat okay
you want to especially in the beginning
of this program add more fat to your
diet and the reason for that is that it
will allow you to fast longer because
programs that are low fat will not be
very satisfying so it's really going to
be hard to go for periods of time
without eating so by adding more fat
you're going to feel more satiated and
you can fast longer now it is true the
more fat you eat the more your body is
going to burn those calories instead of
your own fat but in the beginning when
you're starting this program it's just
really really crucial to be able to fast
longer and allow your body to switch
over from sugar burning into fat burning
and fasting is going to do that you see
as soon as you adapt to ketones
two things will happen your Cravings go
away and your appetite goes away making
it very very easy to stick to this
program and not go up the program could
you imagine doing a program with
Cravings I mean it's like torture and so
when you do this program what you have
to realize is in between the meals your
body is eating okay it's eating your own
fat and that's what we want you to do we
want you to fast as long as possible
ideally and that extra fat at the end of
the meal will set you up to do that but
then as you progress over some weeks and
you're really adapted and you're grooved
in and everything's going good
if you want to speed things up you can
lower the dietary fat okay because
you've already adapted you can lower the
fat not really low but just don't add
extra fat to the diet and that will
allow you to tap into your own fat more
than the dietary fat all right number
four we talked about nutrients when
you're doing this make sure you do
electrolytes as well as B vitamins I
recommend nutritional yeast as one good
source of natural B vitamins both of
these sets of nutrients the minerals and
the B vitamins will prevent
most side effects from doing a fat
burning ketogenic plan like keto fatigue
keto rash keto blue and is an important
part of these nutrients sea salt is also
very important because what happens as
you reduce your carbs you're going to
reduce a lot of fluid in the body and
with the loss of fluid comes a loss of
electrolyte sides and salts and if you
don't add those back in you might do
this fat burning program and feel kind
of weak feel some lethargy Etc so make
sure you take these nutrients as you do
the ketogenic plant as well as doing
fasting all right number five you want
to add something desirable pleasurable
to this program to make it so you don't
feel deprived so many people are giving
up a lot of junk food and then they get
bored on the ketogenic plan unless they
make it interesting or add some type of
food that mimics or resembles some of
these pleasure foods that they've had
for example I like to do chocolate after
I eat of course I don't do this late at
night and the chocolate is totally keto
friendly it doesn't have any actual
sugars it has sugar alcohols it also
does not have these new fibers like the
soluble corn fibers and the tapioca
fibers or the dextrin you want to leave
those out of that chocolate so sometimes
as a little dessert that keeps it really
kind of pleasurable I'll mix some whole
cream with pecans and some keto friendly
chocolate chips for me that is the the
best dessert but there are hundreds of
different um keto desserts that you can
make especially when you start out on
this program because it's all new and
you want to get grooved in so I will put
a link down below so you can go to that
part of my website that I have a lot of
these recipes all right that was a quick
summary of one through five okay now
let's go to six and six is reducing your
stress what you might not realize is
that
experience stress especially chronic
stress is almost equivalent to consuming
sugar okay yes because stress activates
a hormone called
cortisol cortisol or another name for
cortisol is called
glucorticoids okay because it mobilizes
glucose it turns things into glucose
like protein
or fat or even ketones your body under
stress will mobilize extra proteins that
it might not need or have extra proteins
like in your thigh muscle in your butt
muscle and start to use that as energy
when you go through this chronic stress
States there's even a condition called
Cushing syndrome which involves a high
level of cortisol okay and you usually
see this body shape where it's all
midsection skinny legs no butt because a
lot of that protein is then converted
into sugar which is then converted into
fat so we want to reduce stress as much
as possible if you reflect back on your
life and when you started gaining weight
chances are it happened after a stress
event maybe pregnancy maybe a major I
don't know relationship stress like a
divorce or some type of a loss all of
these stresses can severely impact your
blood sugar years so what do we have to
do we have to counter stress it's
impossible to completely get rid of
stress but what you can do is you can
kind of manage it okay so I would
identify those people that stress you
out because it's usually people and then
put them over here for now like just
avoid them for a while now that might
sound like a trivial thing but it's a
huge thing if you were an environment
that did not have any stressful people
and you around people that brought you
up instead of bringing you down your
adrenals would be very very happy the
other thing is to avoid the news because
the news is mostly bad news and
sometimes it's exaggerated bad news and
you just don't need that especially if
you're trying to lose weight I've
mentioned this before in my videos but
physical work even as compared to
exercise can help you reduce cortisol
because it not only mobilizes your body
it gets your mind off problems
so anything you can do to get your mind
off the problem would be a very
beneficial thing for stress long walks
in nature all right number six stress
also relates to seven which is sleep The
more stress you go through the less
sleep you're gonna have when you don't
sleep well you have higher levels of
cortisol this is why people uh want to
snack if they're tired because of this
down cortisol wave that comes up and
down not to mention most of the fat that
you burn is while you're sleeping not
during the day so anything you can do to
get a little more sleep will definitely
help you
real quick story I had a patient who
came in and she went through another
program for a whole year okay exercise
program and um for the whole year I
think she lost one or two pounds it
might have been just one pound for the
whole year okay she was exercising three
times a week two hours each workout okay
when I saw her she was very depressed
and I've isolated not her diet being
that bad but her sleep was crappy you
focus on the sleep we helped her sleep
and guess what she started to finally
lose weight it's really bizarre that you
fix something like sleeping where you're
doing nothing when actuality you're
doing something you're allowing your
body to heal and repair and that's when
you burned fat so if you go to bed a
little earlier like a half an hour
earlier okay and you try to sleep in
another half hour later believe it or
not that will greatly help you lose
weight and you won't be as hungry
because the appetite will be down number
eight tip
um at the very heart
of the problem
with trying to lose weight
is this thing called insulin resistance
okay that is the real cause of what's
going on in your body that is not
allowing the fat to come off easily it's
the thing that caused you to hit this
set point that you're not able to get
below a certain weight regardless of
what you do so what we want to do is
really hyper focus on this insulin
resistance and we want to fix that and
there's a couple things in addition to
the other things I mentioned that you
can do to speed things up first of all
on a regular basis you add apple cider
vinegar like a tablespoon in water okay
throughout the day that is going to help
regulate your blood sugars and it's
going to make insulin more sensitive so
it doesn't go too high it'll go lower so
it'll lower blood sugars and insulin and
then also cinnamon within your Foods is
a very potent
space to help lower your blood sugars
okay like a little cinnamon toast I'm
just being sarcastic okay don't do the
toast you can put cinnamon on all sorts
of things and I have a video on that as
well
the next thing is chromium as a
supplement okay chromium picolinate
supports the beta cells the cells of the
pancreas that produce insulin that can
help you as well
vitamin D is another thing that can help
the pancreas lower insulin potassium
from the salads you're eating the
electrolyte powder can significantly
improve your blood sugars and then
vitamin B1 is also really important
in helping with insulin resistance all
right number nine exercise not just any
type of exercise but a combination of
both types of exercise okay I'm talking
about
anaerobic anaerobic and what I mean by
that is the the type of exercise that
can be done without oxygen like the high
intensity interval training type
exercise
and then the other exercise with more
oxygen that's called aerobic like
walking hiking uh riding your bike that
type of thing I would combine both so if
I were you I would do some type of high
intensity exercise whether it's a spin
bike
weights plaid metrics pulling the sled
and there's just a million different
type of exercises but here's the thing
you want to do it to the point where you
are going to be sore not just the next
day but the next three four five six
seven days that workout has to be
significant okay I have a lot more data
on that I will put a video down below
but you want to do that so you're really
breaking down the body so in the repair
process you have this huge Spike of
growth hormone which also is going to
mobilize a lot more fats okay and then
on the days that you're resting because
you never want to work out over soreness
so you'll be resting for two three four
five six seven days or more until all
that soreness is gone the other days you
can do the aerobic exercise you go for
the walks go for the hiking low type
intensity workouts where you're not
really getting sore but you're building
up your endurance okay I would combine
both of those in number 10 periodic
prolong fasting this is pure Dynamite
I'm assuming you're doing regular
intermittent fasting hopefully maybe one
meal a day called omed but at the very
minimum two meals a day try to squish
those together but the periodic
prolonged fasting is the icing on the
cake I'm sorry it's that meat and
potatoes of the program I'm sorry I'm
going in the wrong direction there it is
the extra magic that's going to really
tie everything together so at the very
minimum every two weeks do a 48 hour
fast now what's going to happen is
you're going to mobilize a lot more fat
and speed things up
and as you do this you're going to get
more comfortable to the point where you
might be able to do it once a week so on
the weekends it's a 48 hour fast
here's the principle I really want you
to focus on don't eat unless you're
hungry
so many people that I'm Consulting that
I'm talking to to help debug their their
weight loss Plateau I'll ask them this
so you're doing omad right yeah I'm just
doing one meal a day I'm still not
losing weight I'll say are you hungry
before your one meal a day and they'll
go oh no I'm not hungry at all then ask
them why are you eating but why not take
advantage of a loss of appetite and go
as long as you can I've had people
start this program and go five days
without eating yes they're doing their
nutrients their electrolyte powder and
their nutritional yeast and other
nutrients too but they're not hungry so
they're not eating and guess what they
get to their goal a lot faster because
you have to realize when you're not
hungry your body is eating its own fat
and that's a healthy thing it's
mobilizing on this fat and why mess it
up with a meal okay because every time
you eat regardless of what you eat
you're going to actually raise insulin
to a certain degree so for those people
that need to lose a lot more weight you
might as well take advantage of the loss
of appetite because what is the point of
eating if you're not hungry your body is
eating
I guess it's just something people think
that well I just have to eat because of
nutrients well you can take nutrients
why do you need um the other Foods you
only need them if you need energy but
your energy is coming from your fat now
if you have not seen my first video on
the first five tips I think it'll be
highly valuable to watch that so that
way you have all the information and I
put that video up right here check it
out